votre fille jade a disparu c'est ça donc
vous avez été naturellement inquiète à
la différence combien de temps que la
première fois en 2001 pour la première
fois on va parler après puisque sa
carrière fois qu'ils enchaînent là qui a
entraîné les conséquences qu'on dont on
va parler après ne pourra leur intérêt
juste parce que vous avez vécu la
détresse d'une mère voilà on a plus
belles de sa fille on se demande où
aller et on veut faire quelque chose et
forcément aujourd'hui les réseaux c'est
la façon la plus rapide et la plus
efficace pour lancer une alerte allait
donc moi j'ai un message de machines
mercredi soir à 20 heures
ouais
21h38 exactement qui me dit je rentre
avec un petit coeur ma fille elle a pris
18 ans il ya très peu de temps
et jade si jamais elle veut rentrer elle
rentre elle mais on a des couvre-feux
donc ya pas le choix c'est comme ça même
si elle est majeure il ya des règles à
respecter et une demi heure après je
vois que ma fille n'est pas là donc je
commence à m'inquiéter le téléphone
était éteint les messages l'aller reçoit
pas et si jade avait voulu sortir un peu
plus comme tous les ados mort est
harcelé de messages moment encore une
demi-heure encore une demi heure l'art
est un silence radio donc je décide
d'aller dans le marais où elle était où
elle m'a appelé je fais le tour des
endroits qu'elle a l'habitude de
fréquenter jusqu'à 3 heures du matin je
la retrouve pas donc je rentre chez moi
je rappelle encore des copines en pleine
nuit le lendemain matin jade était censé
travailler à 10 heures du matin et elle
ratait jamais une journée de travail et
donc je suis arrivé sur son lieu de
travail à 9h30 10h 10h30 11h 11h30
machine était pas là donc des coûts elle
vous dit je rentre voilà y'a pas de
problème et très vite vous êtes inquiète
pour l ouïe une demi-heure après parce
que on est à côté le marais
à chez moi c'est 10 minutes donc
forcément au bout d'une demi heure
qu'elle soit pas là je m'inquiète donc
donc faisait étape voilà ce que je peux
faire on peut parler de disparition
inquiétante de yahoo c'est trop tôt non
là dans ma tête pas du tout quand je me
dis elle va rentrer elle a débordé un
petit peu mais elle va rentrer donc
11h30 je vous dis allez pas là donc je
décide d'aller dans le marais voilà
après toute la nuit quand je rentre chez
moi dès que j'entends la porte d'entrée
s'ouvrir en bas le porche je me lève je
regarde si c'est elle et rien donc la
wii donc nous on ne vit pas des coupes
et que rien plus de nouvelles pierres
ils sont vulnérables 8 sont cuits du
maire je voyais mes parents étaient
autour de cette table très vite on est
vraiment très très très inquiet tout de
suite on est mais c'est nous les médias
et c'est logique c'est humain cas là
c'est l'aveu donc vous donc vous lancez
un appel dès le lendemain alors non
d'abord je vous dis je vais sur son lieu
de travail là
je vois qu'elle vient pas j'attends
jusqu'à 11 heures à de son lieu de
travail et je vois qu'elle est pas là
mon instinct de maman me dit un problème
jeu là je sais que c'est grave à ce
moment là donc je rentre chez moi je
fais un post une story en demandant de
l'aide parce que les réseaux sociaux
c'est le bon côté des choses on va dire
moi j'étais pas du tout réseaux sociaux
alors quand vous faites ce poste
en fait il fait de mobilisation générale
puisqu'il est repris par pas quasiment
tout le monde et surtout par des plein
de célébrités oui alors je comprends pas
moi sur le coup oui j'ai deux trois amis
qui sont qui sont connus qui ont
beaucoup de lois dordain je sais je sais
pas je ne me maquille à laval et jean
dujardin david douillet cas omar sy de
boulemane et pour le coup c'est pas des
petits contre quoi cdc des comptes qui
on le rapporte au ski sont influents oui
mais moi au début sincèrement je pense
pas du tout à ça moi je fais un post une
maman qui en détresse je veux juste un
appel à l'aide si quelqu'un a aperçu ma
fille je dis comment elle est habillée
ça s'arrête là je moi je suis désespéré
voilà
je suis inquiète ça s'arrête là calé
quatre ans calais disant qu'elle ait 18
ans et mon bébé je m'inquiète voilà je
suis une maman solo je m'inquiète point
souvent dans ces cas de disparition
quand on va à la police s'est pas
refermée parce que diva l'acvf c'est
vous et elle est majeure peut être
partie c'est un copain à lui seul elle
est partie de trois jours à la c'est une
petite crise d'adolescence un peu
tardive en fait la police est ce que
c'est normal ou pas j'en sais rien mais
généralement c'est un autre débat mais
bon dans le vocable c'est quand même
pour le coup je peux rien faire pour
vour aider à faire ce peut rien faire j
étais on m'a dit ah les majeures il faut
attendre 48 heures
voilà ça s'arrête là donc on fait quoi
donc je mobilise 7 stories qui je vous
dis encore une fois j'ai jamais été
consciente de l'ampleur que ça allait
prendre mais il ya une à une il ya un
engouement autour de cette histoire qui
est assez éclectique et très bien
d'ailleurs c'est une très bonne chose
merci pour ça extrêmement important et
c'est cet engouement la capable de
retrouver jade aussi rapidement su
rapidement donc en fait expliqué ce qui
c'est passé en fête commence assez
solutionner cette histoire donc cette
affaire assez solutionner que nous donc
le mercredi sargé marcher tout seul dans
marais le jeudi soir on était six on a
organisé aussi une marche pour
rechercher le vendredi on avait refait
prévu une marche on s'était donné rendez
vous à l'hôtel de ville à 19 heures pour
faire encore le quartier parce que moi
j'ai aucune nouvelle de ma fille
toujours voilà si alors je suis je vais
pas mentir
je vois un message je n'ai pas pu lire
tous les messages de joueurs
d'aujourd'hui mon message il ya plus de
vingt mille messages en attente ben oui
je ne peux pas tous les ouvrir et je
voulais la police page parenthèses la
police l'arrière ferry du touât ne vous
êtes pas du tout non rien ni avec aude
avec votre vos moyens votre enquête vos
copains alors mode on met en mode solo
quoi selon me voilà avec attention je
remercie vraiment les gens qui se sont
mobilisés parce que grâce à eux grâce au
réseau c'est le bon côté
j'ai retrouvé ma fille en saine et sauve
alors que 48 heures donne quelques élans
1 qu'est ce qui s'est passé on sait 48
heures alors sur cette année alors je
suis désolé benjamin gille ya une
enquête qui est en cours d'accord
je
basquiat par la police qui a retrouvé
ses ailes c'est moi qui retrouvait même
s'il accorde ou vais retrouver ou sa
gelée retrouvez tous les détails puisque
je comprends qu'une enquête alors juste
avant je voulais leur dire aussi les
réseaux sociaux il faut savoir que le
jeudi soir donc parce que beaucoup ont
relayé oui mais aller sur les réseaux
sociaux elle a le temps elle cherche pas
à sauver bien moi ce qui m'intéresse et
voilà il ya une chicane qui disparaît
c'est important les gens qui nous
regardent son voilà c'est un vrai sujet
un rang 1 le fait de lancer l' alerte
sur les oiseaux a permis d'en trouver
quelqu'un qui tous une bonne oui je suis
d'accord mais la part d'ombré envie de
dire c'est que on vous a par la suite
reprocher ce qui est bon non mais ça
s'est passé pas ça le débat maintenant
d'accord non là c'est juste que je vous
dis je vois juste un message qui passe
en me disant j'ai vu votre chien donc ça
m'interpelle j'ouvre ce message je parle
avec cette personne pour au bout de
trois messages me dise madame je suis
désolé de vous faire ça mais sachez que
votre fille est morte je né sais de
source sûre notre fille est morte
je suis chez moi le jeudi soir avec une
amie je tombe dans les pommes
voilà donc fausse a quand même parlé de
la delà de la violence des réseaux
sociaux et des tarés qui s'y trouvent
quand même donc voilà je viens dire que
c'était pratique l hadopi non mais c'est
le mauvais côté mais les mauvais côtés
je remercie tous ces gens qui m'ont aidé
et sage oublierai jamais ça sera à
refaire je le referais je vous dis la
vérité maintenant donc je reçois on est
à l'hôtel de ville le jeu vendredi soir
moi savoir que grâce à certaines
personnes qui se sont mobilisées le 36
m'appeler avant le délai légal pour tous
et la police en voilà tout ce qu'ils ont
fait voilà pour faire la disparition
inquiétante grâce à cette médiatisation
ça a accéléré le processus donc ça merci
aussi
je reçois un coup de fil donc bon c'est
un peu donc tout est bien qui finit bien
oui je la retrouve à strasbourg saint
denis d'accord donc sans l'aide de la
police encore une fois de la police et
la crise qu évoqué ce qu'elle vous
raconte ma fille je j'arrive je vois ma
fille blanche d hydrater
salle
tremblant leur antre et ma fille moi je
la mets en sécurité je les attrape tout
de suite dans cet hôtel je l'aï la
trappe jamais en sécurité je la donne un
ami qui était sur place
qui la met en sécurité dans la voiture
et ma fille la seule chose qu'elle me
dit c'est merci maman tu arrives et
actant
d'accord donc il s'est passé des choses
qu'on pût qui s'est passé des choses si
vous avez dit je crois madame c'est
qu'elle avait été emmené de force
quelque part elle a été emmenée elle
n'était pas dans son état normal donc
qu'elle était en voyage
on sait qu elle était droguée et c'est
bien sûr bong et séquestré kidnappé à
louis emmené dans un hôtel à des fins on
imagine voilà c'était épouvantable vous
voulez vous avez éviter que cela
n'arrive donc il ya des gens qui ont été
mis en cause un serment si cet appel à
témoin que j'ai lancé je vous dis encore
aujourd'hui ça sera à refaire je leur
ferai j'aurais pas ma fier aujourd'hui à
côté de moi
d'accord donc ça a été extrêmement
bénéfique
c'est violent maintenant ma fille c'est
une victime
donc maintenant si on peut reparler de
ce qui se passe après en fait parce que
pour vous comprenez bien à cette
histoire c'est que déjà bonne chose a
été retrouvé mais humblement il se
passait des choses il ya une enquête en
cours on va pas rentrer dans les détails
mais est ce qu'on vous a ensuite
reprochées et séné en fait d'une pseudo
polémique parce qu'on a retrouvé en fait
un art un appel vous avez fait sur
facebook deux ans auparavant c'est ça
j'aurai alors oui alors verrons bien
avant celle jouée à la main mais juste
benjamin ce message il faut savoir que
depuis que j'ai retrouvé ma fille en
2020 il est bloqué un cadenas d'accord
bon sa maison que je ne sais pas comment
cette année par estelle et la polémique
mais parce qu'en fait on vous ont dit
voilà c'est quand même curieux il ya en
2020 avait déjà disparu alors disparaît
en 2022 donc en fait tout ça des faits
et je me crois qu'il veut dire attention
tout ça des faits que pour faire le buzz
et pour faire augmenter mon compte ce
qui est absolument épouvantable c'est en
gros la polémique qui est née cette
histoire c'est ça ouais ouais c'est de
là qu'est née cette histoire il ya eu 1
pour le coup un déferlement je crois
qu'il ya un mail à mais un tweet un
tweet de capucine bien s'il
devient sur le feu voilà qui a mis
énormément d'huile sur le feu sur le feu
qui expliquait en fait en gros qui a été
à fond comme on était nous dans une
histoire mais après avoir vu sur son
facebook il ya deux ans elle avait déjà
disparu de la même manière puis réapparu
de la même manière aussi je me suis posé
des questions j'espère sincèrement
madame karine léger ah que vous n'avez
pas pris pour des cons avec ses
histoires aussi grave donc ça c'est ce
bon bah non plus voilà elle exprime
quelque chose mais oui car comment vous
d'abord parce que moi je me demande
toujours pourquoi les gens écrivent des
choses dans lequel que bixente pas une
mauvaise personne dont on aime beaucoup
ici pourquoi à votre avis elle fait elle
fait ce message mais pourquoi elle le
fait je sais pas mais je jouerai je vous
pose la question parce que ça va
forcément le doute alors là l'ami de
doute en fait après l equal connais les
réseaux sociaux cette personne je veux
dire en tue ça ne se souvient même pas
qu'à me connais ma fille aux siens donc
il faut quand même être un petit peu
légèrement pour les gens doutent de
votre histoire parce que massi a déjà
avait fait une fugue en 2020 donc voilà
donc ma fille elle a fait une fugue donc
on n'a pas le droit de disparaître tout
faire une deuxième fut en fait il ya il
ya un nombre légal à respecter pour être
crédible donc votre enfant il ya des
enfants qui sont tus des adolescents tu
compliqué qu'il en faut une adolescence
plus compliqué que d'autres
donc parce que sous pretexe ma fille
avait déjà disparu en 2020 elle peut pas
d'accord mais sans magique les gens
tweet l'a donc de capucine a fait un
mélo du tamil de même il faut attendre
un peu un phénomène boule de neige et
après ça s'est complètement inversée
contre vous contre moi ça a été l'effet
inverse mais capucine elle connaît les
réseaux sociaux cette personne si elle
veut m'appeler alain minimum
d'intelligence elle veut elle a un doute
ce que je peux comprendre attention mais
elle m'envoie mpl connais les réseaux
sociaux donc pourquoi faire ça alors
aujourd'hui maintenant la situation est
la suivante vous êtes harceler pour les
réseaux
malheureusement c'est un peu j'aime bien
le gars et j'ai menacé et harcelé sa
maman c'est sale c'est inadmissible
c'est affreux dire mais c'est monnaie
courante puisque le tournoi qu'il en
soit
les des gens se répand avec des mots et
des phrases épouvantable des menaces
épouvantable on peut pas faire grand
chose puisque ni coup certains comtés
cela il découpa n'avons pas compris et
donc dans aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est un
enfer c'est un danseur et c'est un
cauchemar c'est un enfer c'est un
cauchemar alors là c'est pas alors qu'on
s'en prenne à moi je suis une femme j'ai
les épaules assez dur
ça va pas m'atteindre à partir du moment
où on raconte des mensonges et qu'on se
permet de dire des conneries alors ma
fille je vous le confirme à l'epa sdh 1
alors apparemment donné votre adresse
mon adresse a été mon adresse de mon
bureau comment vous expliquez vous que
vous êtes un peu dans des trains partent
un peu dans le btph oui vous êtes un peu
à jean-louis d'être un peu connus comme
n'ont pas connu moi je suis personne
il est reconnu aux touts les quines
comment expliquer que c'est une espèce
de deux d'empressement à vous à vous
décrédibilisez à dire que c'est pour
avoir un compte qui augmente apparemment
vous avez eu cinquante mille abonnés en
plus ouais non mais moi je vois je
reprends les faits est ce que vous
pensez que je vois c'est une bourgeoise
mais une vengeance
ça arrive il y adhérer numérique
maintenant c'est la grande mode ya des
gens qui mettent ensemble qui balancent
des messages et puis boum c'est tout
seul oui mais une vengeance de quoi je
vais vous répondre une vengeance de quoi
moi je suis pas quelqu'un qui est clé
dans la lumière je déteste ça
je suis une maman désespérée qui fait un
appel à l'aide et au jour d'aujourd'hui
je vis harcèlement de fonds j'ai des
menaces de mort je n'ose plus sortir de
chez moi
ma fille on a dit qu'elle était sdf ma
fille n'a jamais été sdf les gens
connaissent mieux ma vie est là ce qui
me fait mal c'est un moment qui parle
machy allait attaquer et là la maman qui
parle c'est il faut que les politiciens
que le président je m'adresse à lui
fasse bouger les choses on ne peut pas
laisser des enfants et des ados faire
face seule à soir seulement et puis
suicide c'est normal c'est un problème
de talent de l'état maintenant et sa
voix qui lui nationaux mais il faut
bouger c'est pas ils ont été beaucoup il
s'irrite fait beaucoup d'heures pour que
ça je le savais j'ai appelé des numéros
verts
qui était bien sûr le harcèlement
inadmissible alors ce qui s'est passé je
prends pas parti mais tout s'est
retourné contre vous moi j'aimerais
comprendre ces mots c'est là que j'ai
pour le mécanisme marine le mec est
détruit on passe de une mobilisation oui
plutôt positive a parlé de trois abrutis
qui vous font
blague mais globalement voilà une
mobilisation autour de cet événement ce
fait divers et pour qu'on passe de 2
bienveillant amalvy oui c'est arrivé
dans d'autres histoires de disparition
les gens ont été retrouvés comme ça
après les gens qui se sont mobilisés se
sentent floués du p alors je dis pas que
c'est vrai mais j'en ai contacté
certains qui s'étaient mobilisés ils
disent aujourd'hui tout était bidon il y
avait eu d'abord non mais je prends pas
parti un mélange faisait tous on est
tous les élus violemment et c'est il ya
deux ans c'était déjà le même coup c'est
en fait mais je redis juste les choses
il ya deux ans c'était pas même si la
descente dames fugue l'apache huguette
j'explique pourquoi les gens se sentent
floués ils disent madame dit elle a été
emmenée de force pour de sombres raisons
en prétextant une enquête sans rien dire
donc comme vous ne voulez rien révélé du
coup on se dit mais sans rien révéler
oui mais vous pourriez dire mais aussi
selon gilles vous vous êtes renseigné il
savait qu'un procès-verbal en victoire
bien sûr bien sûr mais ce qui se passe
c'est que tout s'est retourné et
aujourd'hui je vous le dis franchement
beaucoup de gens pensent que l'histoire
de la disparition est inventé comme vous
êtes connu dans le milieu de la télé que
je vais vous préparer un livre alors pas
du tout alors germé est d'accord
maintenant que les gens se disent ces
débits donc voilà alors donc j'en ai
c'est vrai j'expose faut savoir lire
pour apprendre la langue et de gilles
quel serait le mobile de ces attaques
elle est l'intérêt et les intérêts
hélas soif de notoriété voilà alors
sincèrement je vais vous dire 10 des
gens madame c'est bon c'est ce que
disent les gens mais les gens c d
inspecteur gadget il fallait quoi pour
prouver ma bonne foi et que je dis la
vérité je suis môme en détresse qui perd
sa fille voilà il fallait quoi que je
poste les photos des bleus de ma fille
c'est ça qu'il faut pour eux que je sois
crédible mais c'est honteux de venir se
justifier et de vivre un tel article de
dire ce qui s'est passé comme je ne peux
pas parler ya une enquête en cours vous
connaissez la procédure judiciaire oui
oui des personnes sont dehors alors
qu'une enquête est en cours que karim
c'est quand même curieux s'il ya quelque
chose de grave que t'es pas un soin soit
qu'on attend vous savez ce que c'est
qu'une procédure que ya une année
d'abord il ya eu cette heure d'audition
il ya une confrontation
la déposition donc les agresseurs sont
identifiés les agressifs mais sont
identifiés bien sûr voilà voilà
maintenant est-ce que ça c'est
l'histoire moi j'ai pas demandé cette
médiatisation encore une fois donc ça a
pris cette médiatisation et je suis là
devant un tribunal médiatique mais c'est
quoi l'idée en fait pas ici un nom mais
pas ici je vous parle d'après je suis là
je vous savez ça chez gt 5 jours sans
dormir là je viens harcèlement mais de
malade je sors plus de chez moi ma fille
je l'emmène juste à l'école le matin le
soir parce que ma fille elle est très
forte et je vais lui montrer une maman
forte en fait mon combat aujourd'hui
même si je dois me justifier et je
trouve ça encore lamentable et honteux
mafia bien disparu voilà ça s'arrête là
l'histoire après tous ces gens qui
veulent savoir ces gens qui veulent je
comprends qu'ils sont mobilisés pas pour
moi et qui veulent des réponses dans
serait apte à leurs données et apte à
parler que j'aurais l'accord de parler
pour un emploi je pourrais en les choses
je pourrais en parler clairement votre
fille n'a jamais pris la parole pour
donner sa version des six chaînes phares
bi lisez votre témoin nommé mais à quel
moment elle est victime
beaucoup de gens vous reproche à m 2 du
crime est à sa place et d'inventer cette
histoire pourquoi elle est l'un d'eux
bas salaires sont payés parce que ma
fille je la préserve à la déjà été hyper
médiatisé et c'est parce qu'elle voulait
non plus je vous rassure mafia n'est pas
de mèche avec moi comme ça a été relayée
ma fille je la préserve ma fille elle
vient de rentrer dans un nouveau lycée
c'est déjà un peu compliqué pour elle
parce que beaucoup de gens n'en déjà
reconnu vous croyez que moi elle qu'est
victimes déjà les pas en état de deux de
parler on n'a pas la possibilité de
parler tant qu enquête n'est pas en
cours on attend des résultats des prises
de sang et de tout ce qui est drogue il
faut savoir que c'est un délai qui est
très long voilà donc ça il faut pas faut
pas l'oublier non plus
parce que la police voilà il ya des
certaines règles à respecter
et là on me demande de me mettre encore
moins où ma fille et de la mettre encore
en danger mais c'est honteux c'est
honteux moi j'ai pas demandé cette
médiatisation je suis là aujourd'hui
parce que je veux rétablir en passe de
devenir oui en tout cas
hexal soit vous ça on m'a demandé ça
fait trois semaines que tout le monde
marcel pourra les survaleurs prg pas que
ces choses vont bien qu'on s'arrange
état que le harcèlement parce que quoi
qu'il arrive c'était ça faut arrêter il
va il a cessé et un assassin m'arrêter
un peu votre fille jade va aller mieux
voilà c'est terminé je voulais vous
remercier d'être passés nous voir si
vous étiez un peu stressé mais voilà
c'était important qu'on est votre
témoignage est con qu'on avance sur
cette affaire